mars c'est le mois de la prévention de
la fraude l'Autorité des marchés
financiers lance un appel à la vigilance
au front de liés aux cryptoactif
vraiment c'est le thème cette année avec
nous Hélène Guilbaud qui est enquêteur
coordonnatrice experte en enquête sur
les crypto actifs à l'Autorité des
Marchés bonsoir madame Guilbault bonsoir
Monsieur Fillon alors par rapport à ces
questions de fraude par rapport aux
crypto actifs c'est quoi le rôle de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers
exactement évidemment le rôle de
l'Autorité des marchés financiers c'est
d'encadrer les marchés financiers donc
de notamment de protéger les
investisseurs en matière de cryptoactifs
on est vraiment moche enquêteur donc on
est vraiment fort
occupé des débusquer les fraudeurs les
gens c'est quoi comme travail quand vous
dites vous enquêter ça marche comment au
niveau de la crypto monnaie mais
généralement on reçoit des on reçoit des
plaintes des appels parfois c'est des
gens qui s'informent c'est ce qu'on
souhaite généralement donc il y a des
gens qui s'informent pour savoir si des
films des site internet sont inscrits
chez nous ou même on fait de la
détection donc on les recherche on tente
de trouver des justement des des sites
internet des propositions
d'investissement qui sont pas qui
partent du Québec ou qui vise
spécifiquement le Québec donc on fait la
détection puis à ce moment-là qu'on a
pas de témoin quand on a pas
d'investisseurs on a des on fait des
opérations sous couvertures donc des
opérations d'infiltration afin de de de
d'anticiper les personnes qui sont
derrière site là et des arrêtés dès que
possible mais ça doit pas être simple
parce qu'en principe les crypto actifs
et la chaîne de bloc et tout ce qui
sous-tend ça
amène une protection quand même une
grande protection comment vous faites
pour aller découvrir débusquer les
personnes qui sont derrière ça mais par
rapport à la chaîne de bloc
effectivement ça amène une grande
protection puisque les transactions
c'est immuables ils sont irréversibles
effectivement mais c'est tout simplement
un registre c'est comme un registre
comptable la chaîne de bloc donc on est
on est quand même en mesure de
doubler tout le monde a accès à ces
registres et vous avez accès à le
comprendre ce registre également
c'est registre là parce qu'il y en a
plusieurs puis on a aussi des outils des
outils de traçage pour nous permettre
justement de faire le suivi des
crypto-monnaies des crypto actifs alors
le suivi des transactions tenté
d'identifier ou vont ces fameuses
crypto-monnaies et pouvoir faire quand
on le peut les bloquer et tenter si
possible de rester les fonds aux
investisseurs est-ce que les fraudes
liés aux crypto actifs c'est aujourd'hui
la principale fraude on vous appelle
surtout pour ça LMF dans mon équipe on
travaille beaucoup sur les crypto actifs
c'est le fond
notre domaine d'affaires principal on a
beaucoup d'appels de toutes sortes de
toutes sortes de fraudes mais quand au
crypto actif ce qu'on peut voir c'est
que depuis 2020 on est passé d'une
quarantaine d'appels à plus de à 700
appels
par semaine par mois par année par année
maintenant à l'heure actuelle en 2023 on
partir de 12 à 15 appels par semaine qui
sont relatives à des crypto actifs et
c'est quoi les fraudes par crypto actif
on voit plusieurs sortes de fraudes ce
qui ce pourquoi on a beaucoup d'appels
c'est c'est principalement des
plateformes des sites Internet qui sont
généralement basés à l'étranger donc
c'est ce qui propose aux gens c'est
investir dans le fond déposé des fonds
sur ces plateformes là il crée des
comptes pour les investisseurs et on va
vous faire fructifier vos actifs
justement à l'aide de transactions en
crypto actif ce genre de plateforme là
on les connaît ça pullule il y en a une
qui ferme il y en a 5 qui ouvre c'est
purement de la fraude auparavant il y
avait des ce type de plateforme là c'est
plutôt du côté du Forex on a eu les
options binaires et là ils sont recyclés
au niveau des crypto actifs c'est à la
mode et vous vous devez faire une veille
tout le temps vous êtes vous lever la
nuit pour surveiller ça une équipe qui
fait de la détection effectivement et on
peut pas on peut pas tout attraper c'est
comme la police il y a pas un policier
combien c'est difficile pour moi de vous
dire on travaille sur de nombreux
dossiers mais on axe aux efforts
principalement sur dans le fond les
placements qui sont à partir du Québec
ou qui vise le Québec évidemment c'est
l'AMF contre le monde parce que ces
plateformes là sont sous n'importe où et
ils vivent ils visent la planète donc on
consente nos efforts les crypto actifs
c'est vraiment il y a beaucoup d'intérêt
sur les crypto actifs de la part du
public sur l'investissement en général
sur les investissements on va faire de
l'argent rapidement généralement si on
entend parler c'est probablement le
sujet dont j'entends le plus parler de
la part des gens que je rencontre les
crypto actifs les Bitcoin qu'est-ce que
tu penses de tout ça qu'est-ce que vous
conseillez aux gens
je peux pas vraiment conseiller les gens
c'est pas mon rôle est-ce que vous leur
dites pour faire attention de ne pas
être victime de fraude ben évidemment la
première chose c'est de valider que ce
sont des films qui sont inscrits auprès
de les marchés financiers d'une part on
a des registres les gens peuvent
consulter les registres on a une liste
des plateformes qui sont qui sont pas
inscrites les plateformes sont
ultimement dangereuses et on a le centre
d'informations d'autorité il y a des
gens qui sont là qui sont disponibles
pour répondre au téléphone pour pour
justement dire aux gens oui c'est une
firme inscrite ou pas donc le premier
élément c'est d'appeler chez nous de
faire leur vérification les gens
on parle pas de finances avec des
inconnus l'idée c'est ça c'est on essaie
de limiter vraiment avec des des firmes
inscrites je voyais que le centre
anti-froid du Canada estime recevoir des
signalements pour seulement 5% des codes
fraudes liées aux crypto monnaie aux
crypto actifs donc
la situation est bien pire que ce qu'on
peut croire je pense que oui en fait les
gens les gens se vendent de leur gain
mais c'est moins évident je crois de de
dénoncer quand on a des pertes
évidemment ça s'adresse à des gens de
tout milieu des gens qui ont aucune
connaissance en finance comme des gens
on rencontre des investisseurs qui qui
sont aguerris des hommes d'affaires des
femmes d'affaires qui qui quand même se
font prendre donc j'imagine qu'il y a
une partie de peut-être les gens ont
honte ou au spa dénoncer à ce moment-là
effectivement et bien sûr la pas du gain
Hélène gilbaud merci ça me fait plaisir
on compte sur vous pour nous protéger
merci bien d'accord merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI